why is screenwriting so hard well is it
hard I guess I'll get philosophical
about it do you mean is it why is it
hard to succeed professionally at it or
why is it hard to actually write a
screenplay you know it's it's not hard
to write one it's hard to write one that
you could be paid for or that someone
would spend millions of dollars to make
a movie from and that's like in a way
it's kind of like saying why is creating
a multi-million dollar business so hard
well it's just obvious why it's hard
it's like it's rare it takes something
special both in the person and the idea
and the how you execute it and all that
like there's a lot that goes into it
it's kind of like that because that's
kind of what you're doing when you
create a screenplay or a pilot you're
creating you're creating a business plan
for like a multi-million dollar business
essentially that someone's got to put
millions of dollars into so when you
think of it that way it's like of course
that's hard because whatever endeavor
you were doing that you were trying to
achieve that result with would be hard
or I should say it would be rare that
you're successful or it would take a lot
of work or a lot of time or a lot of
education or a lot of expertise or a lot
of coaching or a lot of failed attempts
before you get to the one that works and
all that kind of stuff right so to me
it's like the same thing with
screenwriting but you could view it like
you know I'm learning how to play the
piano you know and I hopefully enjoy the
process of learning and enjoy the
process of playing what I can play right
now I don't expect to be playing this to
Carnegie Hall but I am enjoying what I'm
doing and I'm people are hearing it and
say oh that was really good but I'm also
aware that when I read Aaron Sorkin
script or you know JJ Abrams or whatever
oh I can't do what they're doing but I
want to so how do they do it and what is
different from what they're doing from
what I'm doing and it becomes you know
or just like I listen to a great penis I
can't do that well how do they do you
know it's a learning growing process
where if you're successful you can be
famous and rich and have a incredible
life or whatever but like anything like
that
there's gonna be very few people that
you know get to the Olympics out of all
the people doing gymnastics or whatever
so whether you know it's just a hard
rare competitive
Tournament type profession on a
professional level but hopefully you've
enjoy the process and you get something
from doing it so it becomes just a
calling and a daily practice and an
interest as opposed to this thing so
hard is when you focus on how hard it is
then it's kind of strangles the creative
process and the joy from it not that I
don't do that on a regular basis because
writers tend to you know do that but
it's helpful to think I don't have to is
that how you see it as a daily practice
I like that yeah I set aside time daily
for writing and I try to keep that
appointment and I'm also open to ideas
flowing in other parts of the day or the
week when I wasn't sitting down to write
but yeah it's a practice because it's
like it's rare that you have a day where
oh my god this was the greatest day of
writing ever and then the next day you
still feel it was great and six months
later that material or whatever you did
that day was so significant you're
really just doing a tiny little bit
you're putting one brick on an enormous
wall every day and some of those bricks
are gonna be taken down and replaced
with different bricks later maybe all of
them and so you kind of just have to be
like I'm just doing what's in front of
me to do today this is today's task and
I know at least that I can do this or I
know how to start on doing this and I'm
just gonna do this and that's it or I
make it a little further but and it's
just every day you're doing that day's
work so just as let's say meditation is
a daily practice somebody's showing up
to meditate if they have an altar at
home or whatever it is for an hour
they're taking time they're making this
sort of sacred space for themselves
do you consider writing in the similar
things yeah and those two things go
together I meditate as well and
meditating right before writing session
is not a bad idea because definitely it
helps to not have your kind of surface
mind going kind of crazy and meditation
can help calm that and writing goes
better when that is calmed so yeah I do
see it as kind of similar to that in a
way
you